and
all i wanna do
is see you turn into
giant woman
giant woman
oh
that's nice
all right something's going weird i
can't see the chat
don't know
why not
trying to figure that out give me a
second
that's always lovely trying to sort that
nonsense
what if you could get rid of your
kitchen garbage uh
okay well i
i'm gonna have to have it open in a uh
in another window
apparently that's how we're doing this
today
and yes happy international women's day
to all and to all a good night
that is right carowind i fill it up to
the tippy top none to be wasted
good to see you all
yes nevermore live long and prosper
is there a certain hint you're supposed
to do that with i should i'd like i can
do it with either hand does it matter is
there a correct hand to do it on i
should know that
i don't
but
hard to believe i only have three days
of lectures left two placements in a
fortnight in the immersive irish
language community in may
well you've been working for all this
for a while car i'm proud of you
uh just been using your chats the same
with shamelessly plug my batman video
hey
you know what respect the hustle
pretty sure that's al alcohol
why i never
yes ms wicked wolf i'm aware saturday's
video is
going to be about that
right hand oh
okay
um
yeah no i knew about that i'm in the
process of editing that video and
actually having to add
addendums for stuff that is happening
between when i shot it originally
yesterday and now and i will bet you
anything i will have to add
more stuff to it
by the time uh it actually has to go up
uh i don't know i can do it with both
hands yeah like that's that's the
problem with learning how to do it with
either hand
it's like
wait is it yeah if i just only learned
it on the one i would just do it on the
one
uh
i have a lovely uh real flavored water
tonight lovely
i have a parseco cider flavored water
vera have you heard of final fantasy
origins because it's been officially
announced to be square's second
mature rated final fantasy game in case
you're wondering the first was final
fantasy type zero
no i hadn't heard
that sounds awful
oh vacuum of comments so if you didn't
know
what it's about um
there is a bill that just
it had already passed the florida senate
i'm sorry it already passed the florida
house of representatives it's now past
the florida senate which means it will
be in law in florida as soon as the
governor signs the bill which he's
indicated he intends to do
and the
short simplified version is that it
makes it so that teachers
um cannot broach the subject of identity
or
sexual orientation at all prior to the
fourth grade and then from the fourth
grade on it's under very vague
restrictions but more importantly
they have to report any
um
change in a child's monitoring i.e a
child in at the school starts
identifying different way back to the
parents that's now a requirement by law
and any parent that thinks information
has been withheld from them or any
inappropriate material has been provided
to their kids
can
request uh magistrate be appointed and
can then sue the school and can get
their um
their lawyers costs recouped if they win
whereas the school even if they win can
i recoup any of their costs that's the
short version i go into 20 minutes worth
of detail on the
language and body of the bill alone in
this video before i even get to how it's
currently tied to the disney corporation
and then finally and this is the segment
i'm having to continually update the
most how disney has responded to the way
in which it is tied to the disney uh
company so
it's a lot and it's not going to be the
subject of the stream because like i
said this this
nonsense has already been in my head
pretty much all week
uh and i have gonna have to get back to
it getting back to the edit
after this so
kind of like this to be a little bit of
a reprieve
from that
if i can help it
do the restrictions include cis hetero
identities or specifically anything
other it doesn't but that doesn't really
matter because
as a uh
actual practical matter
the
any
parents who are
supportive of
um gay or trans kids are not going to
bring a complaint to the school for
bringing up uh heterosexuality or
cisgender nature because that's not a
blow to the people who are against
any kind of queer identity all that's
going to do is hurt the school the exact
same way that people objecting to any
queer identity would hurt the school so
while in theory as worded yeah actually
if a parent wanted to make an issue out
of a depiction of a heterosexual couple
in material provided to a second grader
they could in theory do that as a
practical matter
i don't think anybody other than a troll
and complete [ __ ] stirrer
would ever do that
and even then
like
i just have a hard time buying it
like feasibly you could make
an argument
that
a move like that could be used to show
just how flawed the writing of the law
is but
it doesn't mean it'll necessarily change
the law because
you'll find one person who'll do that to
try and make a point meanwhile there's
50
parents doing it in the other way the
way the law is intended so like i get
the point you were making but as a
practical matter
it's no difference
uh
the guardian had an inspiring story
about a trans woman in prison for murder
30 years ago bought to transition
changed her life
began with a visiting nun she's free now
hmm
interesting final fantasy origins story
is going to be sort of retelling of the
first final fantasy game that's a very
basic story specific uh specifically
um
the first big bad garland and the
gameplay they've shown it looks cool i'm
sure it looks cool
uh final fantasy games have looked cool
for
ages
doesn't mean they've been that good
um
and uh ms wicked wolf like you may have
noticed uh your comments are getting
flagged to review and then not shown i
need you to take it down a notch i
understand you're upset
but throwing a hissy fit and a bunch of
swears
in the chat it's not the environment i
want to have in general or today in
specific so for the sake of giving my
mods a break
please stop
okay i'm not saying you're wrong and i
get your anger but please
stop
just to let you know i'm watching the uh
this stream the same time as my favorite
film on tv is on the background it's a
phantom thread in case you're wondering
okay so
funny story about uh the phantom thread
so i'm not gonna give my opinion on the
movie right now but
i went and saw it with my friend meg
when it was in theaters
and
like it's a weird movie i'm honestly not
entirely sure what i think of it still
at this point but
um
when it was done
it ended the credits started rolling
there was this couple a little bit in
front of us probably
late 50s early 60s
the guy just turns to who i presume was
his wife but i don't know but he turned
to uh the woman he was with and he just
went
i hated that and it was just like they
were silent during the whole movie and
just how emphatic that was
it's kind of like become a bit of an
inside joke between me and meg just
i hated that
so like
i'm glad you really like the movie but
like i can't think of that movie
without
thinking of that that is the first thing
that comes into my mind
you confirm this it's the privilege of
every parent to be able to embarrass or
tease their kids in some
form or another in a friendly way um
yes with massive swollen asterisks which
is that it is
okay so here's what i'm gonna say about
that
yes but it cannot be solely to the
discretion of the parent to decide what
is a friendly way
and i say that as someone who had for a
time a step parent who justified a lot
of
bullying
as teasing
and
you know i
i get
uncomfortable
uh watching
parents embarrass or tease their kids
i'm not gonna say it's wrong
but i'm not comfortable with it honestly
like
the degree to which i tease my kid
is when it's literally just the two of
us
i'll say something that i know will
annoy her or i know will bug her but
it's not in front of anybody else
and if she tells me with sincerity to
stop i will
and actually i try and make a point of
not getting it to that point so
you know
personal baggage history damage it's
there
uh
what's my favorite genre or sub-genre of
horror in particular do i have a
favorite haunted house story ooh okay
so
i
am
oh boy it is it
i'm not even sure i could pick a sub
genre i'm more picky than that
i like super specific films i tend to
like things
here's what i tend to like i tend to
like things that are either
deconstructive of horror or that have
horror
trappings in horror atmosphere but
aren't necessarily horror stories that's
part of why i really like guillermo del
toro he swims in a horror
atmosphere and visual aesthetic
but he's rarely telling a
straightforward horror story it's one of
the things i really really really like
about him um in terms of haunted house
stories i'm not sure i have a singular
favorite there's some really good ones
out there though i like the woman in
black a lot uh the others is really good
it's cheesy as hell
but i do like the 90s version of the
house on haunted hill
it's trash but that's a my trash kind of
movie can't remember if i've asked you
this have i ever played bioshock the
original bioshock no the only bioshock i
played is bioshock infinite which was
pretty good i didn't think it was
amazing but i actually liked it enough
to finish it which for a first person
shooter game actually says a lot it's
pretty impressive that
um i was able to play the game and not
get motion sick
particularly quickly so that probably
says something in its favor
i speak klingon
uh
no
i tried i tried to
i tried to think if i know at least a
phrase oh give a heart oh god i'm so so
sorry john vinyls there you go you know
what's throwing me off is because i'm
i'm i've i have to have the chat and
another window because like i said it's
not
working on my main setup for some
flipping reason um
so like it threw me off so apologies
about missing that thank you carowind
for catching that i missed it um
excuse me
um
yeah
i tried to think for a second there um
if i if i knew any klingon phrases just
to make it seem like i could speak
klingon um but no i i can't
uh
i have not seen the batman but except
clips and the voice over sounds very
snyder rorschach to me accurate or the
clip's misleading
um
it's kind of in the middle
because the thing is like they're not
inaccurate but they are
unrepresented let's go with that like
that kind of thing in that mood is in
the movie but it's not the entirety of
the movie the thing is the movie is
ultimately it's a noir
detective thriller
and those kinds of movies
are hard to market especially when the
expectation for a batman movie is an
action movie there's been that's why
there's been such a heavy emphasis on
the action scenes and the brutal
beatdowns in the trailer and again they
are in the movie but they're not as
central or as omnipresent as the
marketing would have that would imply
let me put it another way if this batman
was basically
zack snyder's rorschach i would have
hated the movie and i did not hate the
movie so
take that for what you will
i will obviously not be going to see the
secrets of dumbledore but i will say i'm
quite concerned by the complete lack of
tina in the trailers
um oh
is she not i like i've i've stopped
following
anything about it
anything
shape or form so
um
okay
yeah stay lit savings time i am aware
batman is pulp noir no it's too gritty
for pulp noir
pulp noir is usually
a bit more disposable this one's trying
to be a little bit more serious
than uh than pulp stuff tends to be but
that's that's not a it's not a million
miles off
ah
if you want to know the tone of final
fantasy origins
uh in the second trial version they
released after being the first box the
m c jack garland just walks off playing
knockoff limb biscuit oh my god that
sounds terrible
that sounds absolutely awful
oh
like here's the thing
i'm currently in the process
um
are uh
i'm currently
in the process of
working through final fantasy vii remake
uh on my twitch stream
uh be doing that again tomorrow morning
10 30 a.m eastern time come and join me
but
the thing is
uh
if i didn't already know the story and
like the story i would not keep playing
this thing
there's a lot i don't like about it and
i think i just need to
swallow the fact that final fantasy
hasn't been what i like about final
fantasy
since 12
and even 12 was a bit of an outlier
in a lot of ways because
six is my favorite
easily
seven's good but there's it there's some
stuff in there it's like what the hell
what the hell
uh eight is not very good i'll say that
flatly eight is not final fantasy 8 is
not good
um
final fantasy 9 was pretty good but in a
way that felt more like trying to evoke
the past rather than
um repackage it as something new so i'm
not a huge fan of that
10
i honestly
don't remember almost anything which
means it didn't annoy me and it didn't
take me off but like it left very little
impression i didn't play 11. i like 12.
i like 12 a lot
but
this this franchise and its
sensibilities have just they've gone off
the rails for me at least jon vinyls
once again thank you kindly the two uh
haunted house stories i love most to
hear your thoughts on haunting of hill
house book 1963 version 1999 version
and tell me i'm worthless by alison
rumfett don't know that second one
haunts game of hill house have not read
the book
have seen the 1963 version holds up
surprisingly well at this point it is
nicely atmospheric pretty well done a
little data but not too bad still works
and the 1999 version i've also seen
which is laughably terrible like that
that is that one's in a category of
hilariously bad
the cgi especially like it was already
not a good movie but then the cgi ghost
oh my god they're so terrible
i think honestly
that was the movie that like
made that made me stop being
enthusiastic about cgi
way back in 1999 because i watched that
and then i thought to the ghosts and
ghostbusters from 1984 and they looked
a billion times better and more
convincing it was oh that movie is so
bad it's so bad
captain omni
thank you very very much
um
let's see i got into an argument with
someone who claimed it would be
impossible for superman to be non-binary
despite superman being short for
superhuman
i mean
if the entire basis of their argument
was
the wording if they're only making an
etymological argument then that's
that's really flimsy to be basing
declarative statements on
so yeah no i'm not i'm not gonna side
with them on that
uh
would with the recent announcement of a
chrono cross remaster do you think
there's a chance we could finally get a
third chrono game nope
no i don't i think
what anything chrono related would have
to be today
to
measure up
to the modern equivalent of what chrono
cross was when it came out or what
chrono trigger was when they came out
would cost
way more money than they're going to
sink into a dormant franchise
do i have a favorite piece of australian
media be it tv show or movie uh yeah i'd
say it's probably the man from snowy
river which i did a review on on the
break room of geeks month month or two
ago yeah
if you can go back in time and see your
11 year old self what would you tell
them
um
keep wearing the dresses they look good
on you
what to what to me is final fantasy
to me final fantasy is the story but as
time has gone on final fantasy has
become about spectacle and nonsense
because
like starting with seven it started to
be about both of those things
it started to be much more about the
visual presentation and like final
fantasy 6 a good visual presentation for
the time but the visual presentation
never felt like it came at the cost of
anything else
since i would say definitely since 10
the visual presentation has been put at
such a priority that i feel like it is
an at an active detriment to other
things
also final fantasy
10 was where they really started
messing with the combat system and
they've now completely started redoing
that every game
despite the fact that they have had good
systems that they've just let go to
waste to bring in these weird freaking
hybrid real-time and turn-based systems
which are crap they're terrible i'm
sorry they're awful so it's
it's less that i have a definitive idea
of what fan of what final fantasy is
rather it's that the aspects of final
fantasy that i do not enjoy have become
more and more and more and more
prominent as the series has gone on the
visuals have become more important than
anything else the stories have
just become more and more and more
utter
nonsense
and the
desire to be innovative
with the magic and or combat system has
taken a priority over making it actually
any freaking good so
that's the short version keep getting
keeping in mind there's a bunch of them
i have not played beyond a few minutes
because i got turned off very quickly
who's the better batman michael keaton
christian bale robert pattinson keaton
still keaton
cara thank you so much you get a heart
would love to know if you're working on
any writing i know galley one took a
chunk of time um not at the moment i i
was writing has had to take a backseat
while i work
uh and try and focus on editing the
audiobook for dreams of fire
because i have all the recordings from
the narrator who i hired um so i i need
i need to edit that so i i have
currently closed down
writing projects and the time that would
be writing is going to editing that
because i need to get that done
just started watching star trek the
original series and was surprised by the
amount of non-villain racial diversity
for the time oh yeah for the time it was
insane how diverse that thing was
i know you love legends of tomorrow in
general what do you think of the show
after season three your last video about
it was right before season four i still
love it
i still love it
it's still
utter nonsense it knows what it is it is
unabashedly stupid i still love it i've
seen it through season
six because i think it's seven that's
airing now and liz and i watched the
most recent season that's on netflix so
that's six i think i still love it
so i've seen some lgbtq people calling
for a boycott of disney stuff because
they're continuing to donate to the
florida gop despite the don't say gay
bill thoughts on that
i don't know because
like here's the thing
i'm not in a position to call for a
boycott because i can't afford to
boycott them too many properties that i
talk about that are part of my job and
what i do for a living are under the
disney umbrella i cannot afford to
suddenly boycott and stop watching and
stop talking about the mcu star wars
um and and
just even disney and pixar movies in
general i can't afford to do that i just
can't so
the very idea of calling for a boycott
is something that i feel kind of
hypocritical making a stance on either
way because if i say i shouldn't do a
boycott it
if i say people shouldn't boycott it
makes it look like i'm just covering my
own ass for the fact that i'm gonna have
to keep talking about this stuff because
it's my job um or
if i say you should boycott i look like
a hypocrite because i can't do it um
what i will say is
i understand anyone who makes the
decision to do that
and i support them in doing so
i also do not harshly judge anyone who
does not make the decision to do that i
get it
either way
and in this particular case it is a
little bit
so it does really seem very specifically
tied to bob chappic the current ceo in
terms of how disney is managing
this um
this situation and it's it's really
unfortunate
because
when you get a company as big as disney
with as many subsidiary groups and
companies
if you're mad at something the ceo
is doing or failing to do
taking it out
on the animation department
disney plus
disney interactive
lucasfilm
um
the you know the marvel entertainment
comics the movies
none of those people
did the thing
and i'm not generally one
to pull the
um
you know think about
the the damage being done to the little
people don't boy and i'm not talking
about damage but i'm saying like
our ability to send a message directly
to the guy at the top
without
just having to
take shots at all these other people
along the way up
that's messed up and that's just where
we're at with something this big
i don't have a solution
right now but
uh captain omni once again thank you
much appreciated
have i ever heard of atomic robo it's
basically sci-fi version of hellboy
about these uh titular sassy robot it
was made by nikola tesla fun read i have
heard about it i've only ever heard good
things um i have not read it what's my
favorite dreamworks movie uh how to
train your dragon 2
any thoughts on independent horror
creators like trevor henderson creator
of siren head
no thoughts haven't seen any of his
stuff don't really know too much of what
goes on in indie horror like what little
bits i hear about indie [ __ ] just they
don't sound like my kind of movies
because generally indie horror is where
you get more out there horror ideas or
where you get
um you know things that would not get
big studio backing which tend to be
um you know more gruesome or dark in a
way that i don't particularly want to
see
i think the thing for me is i appreciate
when something that is not necessarily
billed as a horror movie can horrify me
like i think that
uh under the skin and annihilation are
some of the most
terrifying
and
worm their way into your brain kind of
scary movies that i've ever seen in my
life
but it also feels weird to bill either
of them as a horror movie if that makes
sense
uh
oh hey aphrodite good to see you and
thank you you're amazing too
gonna duck out early okay cara you take
care
um
angus
thank you so much much appreciated have
you and jesse thought about what about
doing a
watchpot on something neither of you
have seen
um
well
it's going to be a moot point for a
while because we've just started the
records for
babylon 5 which she's seen and i haven't
once we finish that it's possible we
could look into something that neither
of us have seen i think the danger there
is like we want
we want to keep working on things where
we're going to be completionists about
it so the trick there
would be finding something that we're
confident that we will both like without
uh without either us having already seen
it that's gonna be a hard find in the
first place
but generally speaking no that's not
something we talked about
i'm imagining a scene of rimmer watching
batman returns when he's depressed when
he gets to the vicious swathes it's
supposed to be cold scene he goes yeah
been there man
gazpacho soup
grammar
smeghead
rusty ralston thank you so much for the
super chat
this is this disney thing feels like bbc
news all over again from my perspective
as a creator basically is and i am
i'm planning to treat it the same way in
that until things take a different
direction or i feel corrective measures
have been taken
i'm going to start putting a similar
asterisk
note ahead of anything that i talk about
that is disney owned
and i don't want to do that
but i'm gonna because
i feel like it's the literal least i can
do
is to
not let anyone think that i don't know
what they're doing or that i've
forgotten or that i think it's okay
because i don't
but as i said
i've made my job i've made it my job
to talk about this stuff
i can't just stop
i honestly am probably missing out on a
decent amount of money not talking harry
potter anymore
i mean other than to you know say how
much
jk rowling sucks but i've noticed it's
become like a little bit of a cottage
industry
for people to make arguments that harry
potter was never good
which
look there's always been things to
criticize about harry potter plenty of
things
and like legitimately but
like that's just a position that i'm
like
like if that's the position you need to
take to be comfortable with
understanding what a terrible person she
is but like that's that feels real
disingenuous to me as a premise
uh hang on a second
sorry just checking something
hmm
okay
what makes one wise i've been collecting
as many wisdoms from as many people and
dentists who are willing but i don't
feel any different
oh my god
oh well apparently wisdoms do not make
one wise
do i like the song hey there delilah
about the plain white tees
it was i thought it was okay at the time
i'm i'd like don't really care at this
point i've ever have i ever played super
metroid
super nes was my
heyday that was like that was my
heaviest nostalgias all around snes
games which yes that includes super
metroid super metroid mega man x teenage
mutant ninja turtles 4 turtles in time
final fantasy well it was released as
three but really final fantasy 6 chrono
trigger secret of mana tetris attack
oh they're all so good
ah
miss those games
what am i eating i am eating
strawberries
another hunt
jon vinyls first of all thank you
thank you very much for the super chat
oh and i missed a couple earlier i got
to go back for those but another haunted
house story i recommend you see is 1980
george she's scott movie the changeling
i should see more george c scott movies
in general um
truth be told
he's quite a good actor first thing i
ever saw him in i didn't see him in i
heard him and that was rescuers down
under
ah
new type jb lee thank you so much uh
you're tough like a girl pod are you
interested in doing an episode on the uh
mc2 spider girl series it's a comic that
features the daughter of peter and mary
jane it's on the it's on the list
it's on the potential to do list but
realize that's a long list because
there's a lot of stuff that fits the
remit
uh of the podcast so like eventually
probably but
children are that's that's the question
just children of earth like i did a
review of children of earth some years
ago when i stand by every word i said
it's amazing it's depressing it's really
good couple of tiny issues uh probably
the darkest thing new who knew who
certainly if not doctor who altogether
captain omni once again
thank you so much my boy my boyfriend is
angry at the punisher skull
appropriation by supremacist groups
because of the fact the punisher would
kill them his solution is due punisher
arcs where he kills neo-nazis thoughts i
mean
he should
um i have a no okay i gotta be careful i
say this i have a similar issue when
cops appropriate the punisher's logo
which they have done and no that is not
me saying that all cops are neo-nazis um
there is a disproportionate percentage
of crossover but that being said
that in and of itself should be an issue
because the entire idea of the punisher
is he steps outside the law and
is doing
things that when well written
should we should be questioning is that
even a good thing
and more to the point
if cops acted like the punisher the
punisher would hunt them down
that like
that's
such a such a infuriating
misunderstanding and misappropriation of
a character who is not always a good
character frank castle can be written
atrociously horrifically
damagingly badly but when he's written
well
he'd kick those people's asses
jon vinyls once again thank you
very
very very much i think one of my big
annoyances with the shining the kubrick
movie i have many annoyances with the
shining uh is that i feel that a lot of
its appeal comes from creating the
feeling of meaning rather than having
concrete themes my big problem with the
shining is that it's [ __ ]
that's my big annoyance with the shining
it's a bad movie
i have never ever had a conversation
with anyone who tries to tell me that
it's a good movie who didn't cite how
much work was put into making it i don't
care
i do not care
how many takes he did of something i
don't care how innovative any of the
camera moves were i don't care how
meticulous the carpet was i don't care
the movie is bad
if you cannot defend it to me without
citing the way in which it was made then
it's not a good movie you should not
have to cite any of that to me ever to
defend it and i have never
ever encountered anybody who was ever
able to defend it on the basis of what
you would get from it on a single
viewing with no knowledge of behind the
scenes information
plus if you actually take the behinds
behind the scenes information for what
it's worth you shouldn't be watching it
anyway because you are watching the
results of a director on an ego trip
abusing
mentally and emotionally his lead female
actress to the point that her hair
started falling out
it's a terrible movie written by a
horrible human being i'm sorry not
written directed by a terrible human
being it should not be praised it's not
good
it's not a good movie it's not scary
ah
i really hate that movie i really hate
it
what are my thoughts on fergal like the
last rainforest hexis is daddy that's
what i think about that
hit me one time
hit me twice
oh ah
oh
that's
nice
we said first thing you heard george c
scott in for a moment i thought you were
going to say cartoon all stars for the
rescue i have seen that and i do
remember it
i re-watched children of earth thought
it was a commentary on the tory
government's asset to the lower classes
but it actually came out at the very end
of new labor that's part of what's
terrifying about children of earth it's
become more topically relevant
which should scare
everybody
yeah i know king hated the shining but
king hated it because of how it deviated
from his book i never read the book so i
don't care i don't care if it deviated
from the book it's a bad movie
i live in canada and it's alarming the
stuff people are waving around to the
point that i cringe seeing the canada
flag
here's the thing i actually
i'm tempted to put an american flag in
front of my house right next to the
pride flag because i hate the idea that
the far right thinks they own the
american flag
and it's their way of staking a claim
that this is their america
and i don't like that
the the left seems to be afraid to
wave that flag on its own merit
and again that's not me excusing any of
the horrible things done in the building
of this nation or the continuation of it
but we seem to have conceded and it
sounds like you're talking about a
similar thing in canada it seems to have
conceded the idea that it's a right-wing
symbol and that is not a point that
should be conceded
i am someone who's generally interested
in final fantasy origins because
from what i've seen it looks completely
different from any other final fantasy
game
look at jack garland he's a complete 180
to previous final fantasy like
okay but then how is it final fantasy
like
my issues with the final fantasy
franchise has been a slow drift in a
direction i don't enjoy i don't see how
doing a hard spin
is going to be a huge improvement it's
just just means it goes off the rails
faster
i hope that shelly duvall is doing
better now and knows her screams are not
going hurt i hope so too
and actually it's the most disturbing
thing that i have ever seen in regards
to the shining were interviews from her
at the time where she
talks about
how
he was hard on her
but she understood why and it was okay
and there's just something about the
look in her eyes that i'm just like
it pains me to watch her say that and
i'm not gonna try and psychoanalyze
anybody for what she was or wasn't
thinking at the time but that is an
unsettling thing to watch
king doesn't adapt well film wise i've
heard that in general
because like i haven't really read much
of king
so um
i've heard as a general thing that like
the way he writes just
doesn't uh
translate cleanly which like
there are other authors like that that's
part of the problem with trying to adapt
anything by um
either douglas adams or terry pratchett
my favorite characters in final fantasy
6 oh
like i love all of them they're all
really good i've always had a sauce soft
spot for lock um i'm i'm really fond of
i mean i like the thief characters in
general
um
in terms of playing them i have a lot of
fun with shadow
um
i just
actually
so like the gate the game hack
um not actually hack because it's
playing by the rules that i love i love
setzer now setzer is easy to dismiss
because his special skill is crap the
slot machine is crap
but
he has a weapon that he gets later
called the loaded dice and there's the
relic the offering that has whoever is
equipped to attack four times now under
normal circumstances the
offering is kind of crap
because it has you attack four times but
you're only doing a quarter of the
damage you would normally do with a
single hit so the only way in which it's
helpful is when you're dealing with a
group of weaker enemies
you know the character will attack
four of them and spread the damage out
and hopefully take some of them out but
if you're only attacking just one thing
the offering is basically useless
loaded dice
and the offering paired means that he
throws his dice and the offering doesn't
cut the damage on the dice because the
damage is determined by the roll of
those dice so with four rolls of those
dice you are almost guaranteed that at
least one of those is going to hit for
maximum damage of 9
9999 points
uh i loved it when i figured that out
that made me so happy the thing is i
think i actually figured that out on my
own because there was a lot of stuff i
um
i like i caught i read in nintendo power
because i had that or i picked up here
or there like how to get the chainsaw i
read that in nintendo power but i think
i figured out the offering in the loaded
dice myself i was really proud of that
uh
let's see how i play oh bookworm of the
fandoms thank you very much have i
played skyrim it's my new obsession i
started to play skyrim
four years ago
something like that i have it
i've got it for my ps3 i played i think
a couple
two three hours
and it wasn't like i decided i'm not
going to play any more of that i got
distracted and started doing something
else and it's been so long i'd have to
start over now
let's see here
jon vinyls once again thank you very
much isn't it true that cronenberg and
lynch have managed to make terrifying
works without being kubrick level
abusers well yeah
most filmmakers aren't kubrick level
abusers even
not great filmmakers are usually not
kubrick level abusers he's somebody who
like was variant was very talented
produced
very well made films but he thought that
gave him a blanket um
get out jail free card to behave however
he wanted and
nobody stopped him so he was validated
in that behavior
so
it's it's like it's one of the funny
things particularly like with a
conversation of
um
like between joss whedon and zack snyder
now as filmmakers as creators in terms
of their general sensibilities i like
weeding a hell of a lot more than i like
snyder but you know what
i've never heard anything but glowing
this is the nicest guy ever to work with
stories from anyone who's ever worked on
a snyder set
and we've heard the stories that have
come out about whedon
so
you know
it can go in either direction
uh
i feel like clyde barker does a little
bit better when he's directing
adaptations of his books did he ever
direct anything other than uh the first
hellraiser
tara staller thank you very much
uh saying hi are you interested in elden
ring at all no
no i tried playing the original dark
souls couldn't get into it but the more
uh the more
pressing issue is that
fully rendered 3d
environments in either third or first
person tend to have a tendency to do two
things for me one
i get lost
so easy and not in a fun exploration way
but in a
i don't know where the hell i'm expected
to go and i'm clearly doing something
wrong and or i miss something and i'm
getting pissed off way
and two i i'm prone to motion sickness
so no eldon ring is nowhere on my radar
uh
how how am i with fan art of me i love
fan art i love
fan art i love it
i thought of doing something i wanted to
make sure i don't do anything stupid no
please please feed my ego go for it
i gotta watch turning red if i haven't
already oh is it out
when did that come out did that come out
i was planning to see it but i
like i have not been keeping
track
i've been busy
um
oh geez
yeah
oh okay no now it's not out in the u.s
yet it's not out in the u.s until
friday
um
if it's gonna be on disney plus
i'll probably see it
um
even if not i might might take the kiddo
to see it i don't know we'll figure it
out
um
captain omni once again thank you
very very much
no sane person would want to be the
punisher to be him you have to have your
family killed in front of you proved uh
most don't get him yeah
like that's the thing he's not a badass
he's a
badly
horribly
damaged human being
ah yeah
last week i spent over an hour trying to
figure out if i could email my audiobook
of service detail to you and i found out
the audio books available in the us and
i didn't need to yes and i did i did get
that i did secure my copy so we don't
have to worry about that i'm still not
going to get to it for some months but
i do have it discord yes i'm on that
carowind just a second because i know
there's a super chat i haven't gotten to
yet
uh
new type jb lee there it is thank you
uh since you said your criticisms of the
ditko era what do you think are the pros
and cons of the lamida of the lee ramita
run of spidey for me gwen became really
boring i haven't read enough of uh the
specifics to really be able to comment
on gwen
i will say i like ramita's art a lot
um and i i feel like he he just
the general vibe and feel and tone of
the thing
is more what i want out of spider-man uh
in terms of
goals aspirations and and uh
you know hopefulness
the the lee ramita spider-man isn't
bitter the way the ditko one was um
he deals with a lot of crap but it's
more you know sort of parker luck
rather than
being
a bit of a [ __ ]
do i play call of duty heck no
absolutely not
no interest
uh no judgement for anyone who likes it
i am gus thank you so much theory most
horror and scroungy filmmakers are nice
people having purged their souls while
those who make kid-friendly nickelodeon
fair are screaming into the abyss
um
like possibly
in some cases i'm sure oh clyde barker
directed night breed okay
i didn't realize that was him
makes sense actually in hindsight okay
i'm checking the discord real quick so i
will be back in a minute
and as a reminder the council of geeks
discord is a patreon exclusive perk if
you are a member of the patreon you have
access to the discord and that is the
other way besides super chats that you
can guarantee your comment or question
will be read
so
first up so this is my second attempt at
asking this question on the discord
since i think i missed the last live
stream by a hair and i've been wanting
to ask this since last october but was
just never able to find the timing uh
right until tonight have you heard of
the horror web comic the order of the
black dog by queer artist rebecca raptor
it's basically a mix of the x-files scp
foundation and the furry fandom it's
about a lesbian couple trying to figure
out a mysterious infection known as the
black idol
along with a lot of other eldritch
horrors along with a small old western
arc in the middle just for fun i had not
heard of that one
i haven't checked out a webcomic in
oh
my gosh
probably going on six years now was the
last time i checked out a webcomic
but now that i mean it's an interesting
mix
certainly
uh and when does the babylon 5 re-watch
start well well for me it has already
started
um
last night uh the record was done for
the review of the gathering the pilot
movie
so as far as when will it be released
two weeks from this past monday so not
this monday coming but the monday after
that will be the start of that so
there we go and let me just pop on back
and here we are i'm back
i'm back baby
have you ever tried getting into voice
acting sort of like i'm really bad at
networking and i really need to put
together a proper voice reel because i
haven't yet like i tried to once but
then i got really self-conscious that i
sounded like absolute garbage and was
trash and i'm like nobody should ever
hear this so
i just stopped
but um
yeah i would love to do more voice
acting i would but like
i i
i don't have an agent i suck at uh
networking and it's just
babylon and on and yes that's that's
what we will do we will be babbling on
about babylon
my mom wants me to see a therapist who
believes uh pretty much how she does
she's a far right christian extremist
of course she wants a therapist who
already agrees with her that
my thympani's
thympani's sympathies
what the hell was that my sympathies
uh karasu i think it was because i was
trying to prep to say
um say your name
and it like
that just that just sent my brain off
the off the rails
want to hear something stupid siskel and
ebert thought that black cauldron is
better than return to oz
they weren't right but i don't think
that's a clear-cut case where you could
say that it's an opinion that's stupid
because like they're both
weird movies
which classic uh who are you am i
reviewing the break room next oh uh crap
i gotta get on that actually um let me
double check what it is because
like
i i i know but i'm now i'm drawing a
blank it's b it's been determined i'm
just trying to remember nope it wasn't
that where was it where was it where was
it where was it
here we go
it is
vengeance on varus
that's the next one
i gotta get to that soon otherwise it's
gonna get towards the end of the month
and i'm gonna miss it again
um
i'm someone who uh loves it when a
company takes a known ip takes in a
different direction to avoid stagnation
while it's a 50 50 whether it's actually
good i'd still appreciate it
i mean
i would kind of rather they just elevate
a new property but they won't do that
because attaching it to a known ip is
risk avoidance so you know
any recommendations for fanart
any recommendations for fan art star
trek commander or eldritch eldritch god
oh hello
please
that like sheer originality i am here
for that i've seen myself in star trek
garb which does not look too bad on me
and i would have no problem with seeing
more of but
ha ha how is that even a
question are you a god
uh
when someone asks you if you're a god
you say
yes
yes a sixth doctor story my favorite
oh dear oh dear oh dear
best uh hellraiser line is in the second
film when the doctor comes out of the
machine after he's been transformed and
to think i hesitated i still
really like the uh the classic line
from the original film
we have such sights to show you
i love that i just i like that such and
the way he says it it's just so
threatening
oh i love it love it so good
huh do i like siskel and ebert
i mean when i was younger i kind of did
i don't i don't like latch onto credits
too much anymore but when i was younger
like watching their reviews or reading
them
like helped me get a sense of how people
approach things critically even though i
would frequently disagree with one or
either or both
of them
vengeance on varys no no wrong show for
that
um do i still watch epic rap battles of
history i actually never reliably watch
those i've like seen a couple here or
there but like that was never a channel
i was subscribed to or like kept up with
ah
oh geez it's almost eight
that time flew by
doug bradley was such a chilly and
commanding pinhead he really was
he was really good although
visually
i kind of prefer the chatterer
now pinhead works as the combination
of that visual in that voice
but going by
visual only
i like the chatterer better
just something about the no eyes and the
um the skin pull back and
unsettling in the best way
do i have a favorite comedian
um
i don't know there's al there's a lot
who i like i think i will always have
the greatest respect
for george carlin
uh as a comedian
i just watched your aztec review to be
honest i was afraid to watch it
i was afraid to watch the aztecs so
there you go clive barker's a fan of
doctor who by the way that tracks that
makes sense to me do i prefer necklaces
or bracelets necklaces in general um
things on my wrist i'll wear for a
little bit but like they ten they tend
to bug me because they either have a
tendency to be too tight or like they go
back and forth and when they rub
on that on the on sort of the wrist
joint that bugs me what about richard
pryor i
i appreciate richard pryor he never made
me laugh the way carlin did
i know the general debate for greatest
comedian of all time is pretty much
between carlin and prior like i'm aware
i'm excited to see what jamie clayton
does as pinhead in the reboot i mean if
the reboot happens like they've been
talking about rebooting it forever
an example of what i'm talking about is
final fantasy 7 remake because square
took the original story and changed it
up in my opinion in a good way jesse
biggs wedge um
in the og was death fodder so like
i've expressed some of my
general frustration with final fantasy 7
remake it's pretty much all gameplay
related
most of the story stuff i meant although
like the nas goals they are taking way
too long to give some flip and
indication what the hell is going on
with those and so at this point i'm just
annoyed every time they show up it's
like oh it's the thing that i don't
understand again
so like that part is kind of annoying i
i'm i'm in favor of the fleshing out of
jesse biggs and wedge although i wish
they could have had wedge present
without making a fat joke every 30
seconds
didn't need it
didn't need it
what's my take on pure historicals with
uh with doctor who
um
i like it in theory and practice i don't
really enjoy any of them
i like the idea of it i just don't think
it ever really yielded much
pretty sure bill hicks is up there in
discussion as well bill hicks yeah
yeah bill bill hicks holds up decently
although uh i gotta say
you know uh
i don't think i've listened to any of my
bill hicks stuff since i was in my early
20s and now i'm at a point where
he has a bit talking about the fact that
he is a 15 year old girlfriend and like
that makes me super uncomfortable
and like he talks graphically about the
fact that he has a 15 year old
girlfriend now it's been argued that
that itself was a joke because it was
never publicly known or confirmed that
that was true but even if it is just a
joke the fact that he made it makes me
uncomfortable
do i prefer gotham or repo i don't know
they have very comparable energies
though
um
what you said about the shining do we
need to get over the [ __ ] equals
genius trope yeah we kind of do
we really kind of do it's one of the
things i appreciate about the doctor in
general because the doctor is a genius
and thinks their way out of situations
but unless you've really screwed up your
writing the doctor isn't a jerk
didn't think the review would be
problematic i saw the episode title was
afraid up fair enough i should wrap it
up is doctor who my favorite show
uh what are some runner ups doctor who
is my favorite show
other shows that i really
deeply love i
okay i gotta think here
um
i really like gargoyles
i like sheer on the princess of power
princesses of power i like arcane a lot
but that one's provisional on how future
seasons turn out because there's plenty
of things with great first seasons that
fall apart
um
i like futurama
um
[Music]
farscape
red dwarf
legends of tomorrow
those are some
i i don't have a like a fully ranked
order there
so yep we are
uh we are we are going to wrap it up
ducktale i like the new ducktales better
than the original i don't think it makes
uh makes it towards the top spot though
it's good stuff though yes twitch
uh tomorrow before uh i forget
10 30 uh council of geeks on twitch i
will be continuing to work my way
through final fantasy vii
remake
hopefully i can wrap that up soon
because i'm kind of i'm kind of over it
but i want to see where they're going
with some of the story alterations so
i'll stick with it
but
whatever
uh in any case
thank you all for joining me this was
this was nice this was
the casual relaxed time i
really needed
thank you all for
being here thank you for your thoughts
your questions your company
i really appreciate it
and uh please remember
that you are beautiful
you're valid
you are loved
my cavity